[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
hace pocas semanas fueron las elecciones
pasó en nuestro país y dentro de unas
pocas semanas van a ser las elecciones
generales
al espacio que de repente ven a la gente
un tanto como decirlo y naciones fuertes
eufórica a la hora de discutir
lo cierto es que ese clima de discusión
política y más con unas elecciones en
puerta puede tornarse un poco tenso
son ocasiones donde ciertas amistades se
ponen en pausa y donde esa bendita regla
de ni política ni de religión discutimos
en la mesa se pone bien firme
igual esto no tiene tanto que ver con lo
que les contaron o tal vez un poquito sí
mi nombre es dios aquí el carnero
elevará voy a el último año del colegio
nacional de monserrat y tengo 18 años de
los cuales ha dedicado poco más de un
tercio a la política estudiantil más
específicamente a trabajar en centros
estudiantes de mi cole y en algunas
organizaciones estudiantiles hoy después
de algunos años de trabajo tengo el
honor de presidir el centro de mi cole
así que vengo a hablarles un poco de eso
de centros estudiantes y más
específicamente de centros estudiantes
secundarios
no les quiero mentir sus sospechas
probablemente sean ciertas todos los que
nos metemos al centro de estudiantes lo
hacemos con un único propósito y el que
se imagina en salir un rato de clases
pero al final todo nos terminamos
quedando por algo
algunos los gatos las amistades a otros
de contención a otros porque no algún
amor y siempre estarán compartiendo las
ganas de ayudar en lo personal me que
por todo esto que nombré antes pero no
sólo por eso
con el tiempo me di cuenta de que soy un
apasionado de la política y de que el
centro de estudiantes me da una
oportunidad única y distinta de
participar en ella
en lo personal veo que tenemos una
sociedad hiper politizada todos acá
tenemos una opinión del deber ser todos
nos tomamos un taxi y vamos discutiendo
con el chofer acerca del último
escándalo mediático del gobierno sobre
el mal estado de las calles o cómo van a
hacer esta hora acá cómo van a cortar a
casi 200 metros adelante es más práctico
pero todos tenemos también una tía
esther o un tío rubén que en la mesa del
domingo esa misma en la que no podíamos
hablar ni de política ni de religión se
ponen a discutir con una elocuencia
propia de un foro económico en davos
sobre la política económica del gobierno
de turno
pero al final del día cuántos somos los
que nos ocupamos de que ese deber ser
efectivamente sea
la verdad que la dictadura
cívico-militar del 76 al 83 ha dejado
una herida abierta que es difícil de
agarrar y que tiene mucho que ver con
ese alejamiento de la política
meterse cuando hablamos de política es
un paso difícil de hecho lo primero que
me dijo mi mamá cuando entré a el món se
fue diego no te vas a querer meter en
política al segundo día era delegado del
curso así que perdonaba
pero realmente si me metí es porque era
muy distinto a ver quiero ser claro
entre el colegio en el año 2015 con un
programa político igual o más polarizado
que la actual el contraste era enorme
con el clima de convivencia democrática
que teníamos dentro del centro de
estudiantes donde había dos listas de
diferentes pensamientos trabajando en
conjunto como un equipo por el bienestar
estudiantil
con el tiempo me puse a pensar cómo
podríamos hacer realidad efectiva
para la política nacional esta utopía
que vivimos en los centros de
estudiantes y encontrar la respuesta en
la misma pregunta que había formulado en
los centros estudiantes
antes les comenté por qué nos metemos y
por qué nos quedamos en el centro lo que
no les voy a contar es todo lo que un
centro estudiantes puede llegar a
producir lo primero es una comunidad
organizada y unida con objetivos comunes
y claros un grupo de jóvenes organizados
o alguna causa es absolutamente
imparable y esto lo vemos en ejemplos
nacionales e internacionales hay alguien
viendo esto que no sepa de qué hablo
cuando digo cambio climático
probablemente no e incluso me podré
nombrar a alguno de los factores que lo
provocan y si esto es posible es gracias
a miles de jóvenes a lo largo del mundo
que organizó pusieron la problemática en
la agenda este esquema se repite con
cada cuestión que por alguna razón se
nos ponga por bandera
el centro de estudiantes realmente te
forman creces de una manera personal
pero sobre todo colectiva aprendes
aprendes escuchar aprender a aceptar
aprender a tolerar
aprendes que la política no tiene por
qué alejarte sino que te debería poder
acercar y siguen ejemplos estos sobran
para traer a colación lo bien concreto
en la gestión actual del centro de mi
cole la coordinó junto a otras tres
personas con la que muchas veces estaban
listas opuestas con las que en la diaria
tengo diferencias y esas diferencias
sabemos construir propuestas superadoras
y esta mecánica de trabajo ha
consolidado una relación de amistad pero
sobre todo el compañerismo y es una
forma de medir la amistad la política y
la política que le voy a enseñar conmigo
siempre y que voy a intentar contagiar
por donde me toque caminar
ahora la pregunta es que estamos
haciendo que no estamos creando centros
estudiantes o mejor aún porque no
peleamos por una ley de centros
estudiantes podríamos hacer algo
nacional o tal vez algo provincial para
empezar lo cierto es que ambas liceos
existen gracias al movimiento
estudiantil organizado que luchó por
ellas
lamentablemente la problemática no se
termina en lo estatal pasa por otro lado
para empezar tenemos una problemática
coyuntural la pandemia un año y medio de
pandemia nos ha alejado el centro
estudiantes como espacio de encuentro
empezó a sufrir porque la pantalla nunca
pudo suplir ni al aula ni el pasillo ni
el oficina del centro seguirle el rastro
de tu compañero el que necesitaba algo
se hizo difícil
por otro lado hay una cuestión que nos
atraviesa como sociedad que está
proliferación de los discursos
individualistas el acá todos nos
hablamos solos cuando si algo nos ha
enseñado este último año y medio de
pandemia es que de ésta y de las más
difíciles salimos entre todos
pero no todo está perdido somos muchos
los centros estudiantes que nos
mantenemos activos día a día con
actividad diaria por el bienestar de
nuestros compañeros pero podríamos ser
muchísimos más y para eso te necesitamos
a vos para empezar si 6 en el colegio y
tenés centros de estudiantes acerca tu
propuesta
conversa con los chicos es muy probable
que encuentres un lugar de contención
si por el contrario está en el cole pero
no está en el centro de estudiantes
organízate con tus compañeros
comentarles la idea de hacer un centro
porque no sólo es un derecho sino que es
una experiencia de aprendizaje la que te
vas a cerrar un montón de anécdotas y
she's a tease fuiste del colegio y
querés formar parte de la construcción
de los centros también lo puedes hacer
con cosas simples como realizar una
donación o una gestión al centro
estudiantes del cole de tu barrio o de
tus hijos para que puedas realizar una
actividad o con cosas más simples
todavía como acompañarnos cuando decimos
meternos en política porque les aseguro
que si ponemos a los centros estudiante
en agenda muchas cosas pueden cambiar
pueden mejorar para empezar vamos a
ponerle un freno a los discursos del
odio y vamos a darle un empujón a los
solidarias
vamos a consolidar una ciudadanía
comprometida con su presente cuya
trayectoria está marcada por la única
intención de ayudar y cuya costumbre
política sea construir desde el que
encuentro y no desde la supremacía
y tal vez así volviendo lo que desee en
un principio podemos volver a hablar de
política en la mesa del domingo darle
las elecciones no causen ninguna amistad
también tal vez discutir políticas no
nos pongan tan eufóricos como bueno eso
probablemente nunca pase pero todo lo
otro sí y sobre todas las cosas
vamos a consolidar una dirigencia
política capaz de construir la política
de los centros de estudiantes la del
encuentro la del consenso y la la y la
de la pluralidad muchas gracias